buenos dias angela precisamente son más
los votos rurales que los del extranjero
que van a inclinar se dice hacia pedro
castillo probablemente las estadísticas
que se vienen contabilizando hacia este
momento en el voto rural es donde se
encuentra la fortaleza de pedro castillo
eso es lo que lo han señalado diversos
analistas pero es precisamente ahí donde
el poblador conocido con el poblador el
perú profundo es que ha visto en pedro
casi más que un candidato una
materialización de su reclamo de su
protesta contra un sistema político
sistema económico que señalan que los ha
tenido abandonados aún faltan por
escrutar más o menos dice la oficina
nacional procesos electorales el 11 por
ciento de las actas que vendrían a ser
más de nueve mil actas y esto es lo que
está retrasando el conteo actual